i want to ask one immigrant question
okay go i i've seen some of your videos
on being an immigrant how fortunate that
is love it now you said something about
how every generation after you is softer
yes i feel like i see that with my
people you probably see that well
russians are probably so hardest but how
do you curb that is there a solution
because my kids i do worry they're going
to be soft little little baby shits
couple things one you can't fake
environment
this is a very big thing for all the
parents that are struggling with this
you can't send your kids
to africa for a week to build schools
and think when they come back and are
flying private planes and live on the
upper east side and go to private
schools and live in the hamptons that
they're going to get perspective
you can't fake environment
i believe what i've learned and in as i
had kids and then i was like wait a
minute this is gonna happen for me i
kind of locked in and looked around on
the people i knew best i'm like why are
they completely [ __ ] up and why are
they so solid even though they came up
with so much i think the biggest thing
that i believe
helps they're gonna be softer but that's
okay
are they capable of being kind
and appreciative becomes are they
entitled and think they're special
because of your money or
are they empathetic kind and aware
and navigate their life on that and do
they have their own self-esteem around
them
because a lot of people struggle with
like look
if one of my kids two kids are an
entrepreneur
they're gonna get murdered by society
they're gonna be like your dad did that
and that sucks yeah like i think it's a
much bigger advantage to come build your
own thing than to be in a position like
everyone's like oh they're so lucky
what but that's that's your ego
a hundred percent
because they could have said that about
you with your dad and then you blew that
[ __ ] out the water so they could blow
you out the water they could actually
buy the jets look everybody they could
they could they could if they have
self-esteem
because if you don't have self-esteem to
your point then that judgment destroys
you well that's on you and your wife a
hundred percent those are you gotta
build but guess what lots of parents
through the years have had huge had huge
good ambitions to their kids and dna is
a [ __ ] dna's a [ __ ] dna
you can't control everything dna is a
[ __ ] mother and circumstance you
might get one you know environment
matters every one of us right here would
be stunned how much a single best friend
in third fourth fifty sixth three yeah
meant something
or you meant something yeah and it's
just cool like that yeah yeah
okay final question because i know you
gotta get out here
in a way your currency
is your ability to predict these trends
as you get more successful
do you feel an increased pressure to be
right
in the same way a warren buffett needs
to be right every time he's moving so
much money you're giving influence to so
many other influential successful people
being wrong in a big way could hurt
maybe your relationship with them how do
you one do you feel that stress and two
how do you cope with that stress
really
i just want to recall the clip where i
said this show was
funny and entertaining grounded in
intellect that was an incredibly
insightful question
couple things
one i feel no stress about it but let me
tell you why i know
i don't think i know that i'm not in the
predicting business
meaning
um
i've never predicted anything what i am
is
probably no you know this is why i think
i've always loved comedians i would
argue that an overlap that you and i
have
is
social observing
we have to for our material sure right
yeah yeah what i do for a living is i'm
a
human anthropologist watching people
move
and then using my talents to synthesize
thoughts
but what i do with my predicting in
business which is really where i do it
everything had already happened
nft i i looked at cryptokitties in 2017.
nothing i ever talk about is nostradamus
is predicting all of it is fastest
observation to truth
and willing to bet the farm
thus being loud on it once i have my
conviction
i'm there as a matter of fact this is a
very weird thing that i i hope we can
clip this there was a boxer named julian
jackson
in the 80s
i loved him he was a [ __ ] terror he
had like a patrick ewing flat top and
this [ __ ] if he punched people
knocked them out so heavy it was crazy
like more than tyson
i'm telling you please go to youtube
google julian jackson look at this
[ __ ]
look at this dude look at this dude look
at that 46-1 with 43 knockouts scroll
down just a little bit look at that 46
and 1 43 knockouts this guy in a post
game once in a post game you got to
watch them they're crazy they're they're
not normal knockouts for boxing
after one fight he said something i'll
never forget i must have been like 12 or
13. he goes i think he's jamaican if i'm
remembering right so he has a nice solid
little accent and he goes the announcer
is like how do
and he goes you don't understand he goes
when my hand connects with a man's jaw
and i get this feeling in my elbow
no man can ever get up
yeah it was some gangster [ __ ]
i 40 30 years later i'm affected by that
if i do my so if i do my human
anthropology work
and i have my eureka moment
musically is gonna be big
it's next aka tiktok
uber is gonna work look what just
happened in new york i can't believe
it's working here
nfts
gonna
you if i do my work
and i feel that click i will never be
wrong because i haven't for 35 years i
sold all my baseball cards because i was
at a baseball card show in 1993
normal my life doing 15 20 of them a
year i'm sitting there
the doors open at this
high bridge
fire station three people walk in i
listen to one conversation
and i turn to my best friend brandon and
say i'm selling all my baseball cards
and sold the whole collection and six
months later the whole market collapsed
what was the combo
it was just two guys the way they were
talking the passion was gone
[Music]
it was over
and and then i put all my money into
toys
which ended up being right i bought all
these star wars from the 70s and all
these transformers and i ended up being
so right ebay came out two years later
the whole thing popped off
con culture took over i was so right
it's what i'm good at
kobe's good at what he was great at
beyonce is good at what she's gonna i'm
going to be one of the greatest
entrepreneurs of all time not because
i'm saying it because [ __ ] my parents
had sex without a condom in belarus in
19 [ __ ] 75 at the exact right second
and then a lot of other [ __ ] happened
along the way and just here i am and
guess what
who gives a [ __ ] i'm gonna die i have 24
hours of trending on whatever the [ __ ]
twitter is of the day and then
everybody's gonna go on with their
normal [ __ ] life
so i don't think i'm great because of it
who gives a [ __ ] but it is what it is
and so i feel no pressure cause i'm
great at what i do
i felt more pressure coming up because
it was how i got here
i needed all those i didn't have a
harvard degree i was a street kid i was
a licorice i had i needed all those to
get to this moment now it's easy but i
value my legacy so much that i will
never compromise it for any bag
if [ __ ] [ __ ] some saudi plus russian
plus china transformer comes to me the
three [ __ ] wealthiest people from
that company and they [ __ ] in front
of me turn into a [ __ ] power ranger
and they're like
we'll give you 73 trillion in cash if
you just tell everybody that you know
oxygen should be bought like water was
we saw the schultz thing and you should
do that i'd like [ __ ] you transformer
and leave because if i don't believe it
the [ __ ] i had enough money when i made
a hundred thousand a year this isn't
about the money anymore this is about
getting into the [ __ ] entrepreneurial
hall of fame that means your word your
legacy your actions your execution
that's what i'm on guys that clip is
brought to you by blue chew the makers
of hard dicks and happy wives that's
right your girl deserves it even your
side chick deserves your best and the
way you're gonna deliver it to her is
getting on that chew same active
ingredients it's inside cialis or viagra
but this is the true this is the one we
rock with and this is the one that we do
spinal damage to the ones we love with
make sure
you get your first month free by going
to bluechew.com
and use the promo code andrew you just
gotta pay five dollar shipping that's it
thank you so much for watching the clips
keep supporting the podcast we'll see
you soon
you